it's not my pleasure to introduce dr.
Larry PR in the 12th president of
Hillsdale College President Arne
received his bachelor's degree from
Arkansas State University and his MA and
PhD in government from the claremont
graduate school he served as director of
research for sir martin gilbert the
official biographer of winston churchill
and from 1985 to 2000 he served as
president of the Claremont Institute for
the Study of statesmanship and political
philosophy in 1996 he was the founding
chairman of the California Civil Rights
initiative which was passed by
california voters and prohibited racial
preferences in state hiring contracting
and admissions dr. Arnn is on the board
of directors of the Heritage Foundation
the Henry salvatori center of Claremont
McKenna College the Philadelphia society
the intercollegiate Studies Institute
and the Claremont Institute he served on
the US Army War College Board of
Advisors excuse me Board of Visitors for
two years for which he earned the
Department of the Army's outstanding
civilian service medal in 2015 dr. Arnn
received the Bradley prize from the
Lynde and Harry Bradley Foundation he is
a member of the American political
science association the Churchill Center
the council for national policy the
Federalist Society mont pelerin society
and the philanthropy roundtable he is
published widely he has published widely
in national newspapers magazines and
periodicals on issues of Public Policy
history and political theory is also the
author of three books Liberty in
learning the evolution of American
education the founders key the divine
and natural connection between the
declaration in the Constitution and what
we risk by losing it and most recently
Churchill's trial Winston Churchill in
the salvation of free government dr.
Arnn is here a professor of politics and
history at hillsdale he teaches courses
on Aristotle Winston Churchill and the
American Constitution he and his wife
Penelope have four children Henry katie
alice and tony please join me in
welcoming dr. larry yarn
thank you David very much
congratulations to the PI phi's my
daughter was a PI phi and i expect them
to win congratulations to the Sigma
Kai's I think it was only six months ago
that Tom Connor and my Connor were
getting ready to kill those guys now
there are a bunch of scholars well then
knowing the students around here is
anybody else as I am surprised that the
boys get as close to the girls as they
get and I am sorry to report that
Matthew Sullivan did in fact graduate
with a four-point last year and there is
that creeping up thing going on so what
are you guys doing okay trustee Michael
Bozek passed away about a month ago we
saw him the week before he died he was a
Pittsburgh man he ran Sears retailing he
was delightful he came to our reception
in Pittsburgh a few days before he died
insisted on getting up at six o'clock in
the morning to drive me to the airport
he was hilarious and insightful and he
loved our college and our hearts go out
to his family his wife stiffy and his
children I see the chairman of the board
and his wife sitting back there they
live in town now it must be fun for all
of you they're excellent entertainers
and the chairman is blind but there's no
cuddling going on here in fact there's
enormous opportunities to walk him into
things and I'm personally am very
advanced at that now
see now doesn't he feel part of the
place Stanley Ames is here he is the
father of our late colleague Brittany
who died a junior in a traffic accident
in 2014 and I welcome him back and we
remember his daughter with love and
respect thank you for coming sir college
as well financially well done pretty
good last year we just had the last two
years have been unprecedented things
we've just done very well this year
we're not doing that well but we're
ahead of budget and we don't really know
this year's pretty young how well we're
going to do we hope to have massive in
historic events but also we hope to just
make the budget it looks like we can
probably do that academically the
freshman class are very good how many
freshmen are here today yeah welcome to
your first convocation we have to talk
about complication because we have to
make the freshman come I've decided
because you can make them do anything
they don't know any better
there seems to be more stories of the
freshmen avoiding me this year than is
typical and I want you to know I'm
hunting for you and I go find you it's
not that hard our low-power radio
station is operating in some sense or
another and we've hired somebody to run
that thing and Vince Benedetto in
Pennsylvania is behind that whole plot
and it sounds to me like the dumbest
idea ever in history and it's going to
cause us nothing but trouble but so far
it's not any trouble so I'm not too mad
about it right now but the first time
one of you kids get on the radio and say
something stupid which will be the first
time you get on the radio there was an
argument between our basketball coach
and the basketball coach of a prominent
school in our existing athletic
conference about how we could leave such
distinguished school to Sue's own and
others in the GLIAC and our basketball
coach said well you don't actually
understand quite what we do down there
at Hillsdale College it's not the same
kind of thing and so I'm particularly
pleased to say that this year there were
27 of the 400 Division two schools that
won the president's award for academic
excellence and we are one of the 27 and
the only member of the GLIAC to win it
and let me just say Nana nanana
women's cross country is third in the
nation and that means they're slowing
down a little bit I don't know what's
going on there the auspices for
basketball and and that means and both
men's and women's are good the football
team is 14 games in a row i think and
doing pretty good academically if they
win and they're the smartest that's what
we like from our athletic teams around
here what's this day to play too good
we're okay most of our competitors are
collapsing it's a very serious situation
in liberal education the reasons for
those collapse are very deep and they're
threatening to us this fall the federal
government omitted us from their
scorecard we know why that happened now
the reason it happened is it's an
exercise in big data big data is how
google knows you know where you are
right now they actually even know in
fact I can do through google analytics I
can know what every member of the
faculty is thinking about buying right
now well the federal government has gone
into that game right and so what they're
doing is they're taken they have the
income tax database and lots of other
databases and what they're doing is
they're taking the student loan database
and the student loans are a national
crisis you know they actually threaten
the FISC of the richest country in human
history and they're taking all that data
in there trying to paint a picture of
all the colleges in the land how they do
in turning out people who get rich or at
least pay their bills well we can't be
in that really we hope to get mentioned
in it but the truth is we don't have the
data to give them because we're not the
government our loans are private and so
we can't get in that thing probably
that's actually the reason they might
have said that they might have said
were concerned about the national crisis
and student loans of course we're not
going to take responsibility for that
we're going to continue to blame all the
colleges we give money for that but
because hillsdale college doesn't take
our money and also by the way does not
have a crisis in student loans our
default rates are one percent which is
commercially excellent if they were
ordinary loans and we put a cap on how
much people borrow around here and you
guys I mean gosh you're coming here
nearly free there actually is in town
and we're confused for it sometimes the
Hillsdale Beauty College that is the
recipient of federal government funds
and their tuition is not far off hours
and probably more than week than we
actually collect they might have said in
that good wow look at that there even
the kids that go they're going pretty
cheap you know because of those people
who are lined up right there from
visiting you know mostly members the
president's club I see they could have
said it had a grand thing and we're
sorry we left you off but we're prepared
to mention your name in this thing
because you're not part of this crisis
we're trying to deal with know what they
said was because they didn't really know
of course why they left us off it is
after all a big country and they're
trying to run all of it who could ever
know all those details so what they said
was they don't really give degrees there
just certificates now that's not stupid
ass dog stupid
but this powerful place they said that
thing right and that is a mixture of
ignorance and arrogance and contempt
because the mighty ought to think what
they can do because you know we've been
fielding phone calls about whether in
fact we give degrees and we reply what I
replied to the reporter from the
collegian Hillsdale College 1844
Department of Education 1979 they're new
to the game and they haven't figured it
out yet but they have power in the game
and they wish to convert the game around
measurements of how people serve as
factors of production you seniors there
next semester we'll say goodbye to you
you're going to be really great factors
of production but the reason for that is
you are factors of good that is what
your parents want that is what you want
for your own happiness this is what your
country ought to want into doesn't and
that's dangerous so we're going to
soldier on and if we have to fight them
and we likely will then we're going to
fight them hard in the end we're going
to win because the good is not the most
important thing to know only that it is
also the most powerful thing
the daughtry award is given for
excellence in teaching in the spring to
a senior and in the fall to a junior
faculty member it comes from an
anonymous gift from Susan mcnear
a great friend Howard Shaw was just here
Howard is 92 and he's gone back to
flying airplanes he was a pilot in his
youth in the Air Force fought in the war
and that I was flying again and he was
just here and he is Susan their widowed
both of them and they're very close
friends but as as he will tell you when
they're making room reservations we
don't cohabit lest we think that this
friendship is romantic which it appears
not to be and and they're just as close
as they can possibly be and he didn't
bring Susan and so I wrote her a letter
and told her that I was going to respect
in my customary way her demand for
anonymity this semester and that we all
wish her well and we do now this year's
this terms dr. winter is the weirdest
thing I've ever seen there has to be
some I've always thought we rigged this
thing but this this time it's a sign
that we don't we don't rig it right
because here's what's happening the
doctorate winner this year is a graduate
of Hillsdale College he was our
outstanding senior man he dated and has
since married a woman who's in this room
who's infinitely too beautiful for him
she was a really great she was in the
chamber choir used to see her all the
time sitting up there I had a very
lively sense of her when she was a
student and she was an excellent swing
dancer so good that she made her
now-husband look good which was a tall
order he is the he is the hell does ma
and his PhD from upenn he won I never
thought I would read these words because
I didn't know these words existed the
HCL cappadocia prize for best
unpublished manuscript from the society
of italian historical studies i bet the
competition was fierce for that one
the truth is this young man he's a man
now although it's very difficult for me
to admit it he'll always be a boy to me
he has done everything in his life
excellently including being a student
here and now a faculty member here and
so for the first time in my experience
the speaker at convocation chosen
because he was professor of the year
last spring is also the winner of the
Duchy award which cuts some time out of
the program
he is awesome young man and it's
wonderful to have him on the faculty
here he has a Ivy League degree and he
has been told by some of them that you
can go anywhere I mean after all you
have won the nco cappadocia products so
you could go anywhere and teach why
would you teach there and I know he's
told me the answer he gives them it's
love so we should love him back matthew
caetano
mark welcome
we need one he gets money in a plaque on
the department gets money and Blackstock
i think is the one who thought of that
and i think he was just thinking they'll
be jealous if they don't get money to
alright president our faculty staff
students and guests thank you for the
opportunity to address you briefly today
I also want to express gratitude and
it's in absentia to the class of 2015
for their generosity towards me last
spring they arrived at Hillsdale in fall
2011 just as I began my time here in the
history department so there are kindness
towards me was particularly meaningful I
am very humbled to be speaking to all of
those assembled here today so many dear
friends so many who have mentored me not
merely since I arrived here four years
ago but who first introduced me to the
life of the mind fourteen years ago I
owe an unpayable debt to my teachers and
I hope that these remarks are a small
token of this immense gratitude the
communion that we share because of our
pursuit of knowledge for its sheer
beauty and goodness because of the
mission of this place and because of the
friendships that bind together the
faculty students and administration at
Hillsdale this communion makes it a joy
for us to be called together today but
in universities across this country
being convoked to talk about common
purposes poses a serious challenge our
peer institutions face fragmentation
does this result from utilitarian
approaches to education if education is
about nothing but job training then the
university is merely at the service of
those various career goals of the
thousands of students who happen to be
at that place but perhaps more deeply
sus inch such institutions worry about
the possibility of being called together
for common aims because of the idea of
two
cultures famously put forward by CP snow
a lament about the gulf of mutual
incomprehension between scientists and
literary intellectuals why might it be
difficult to gather professors in the
sciences and those in the humanities
some have wanted to put blame on the
hard sciences these critics have coined
the term scientism to describe the view
that the scientific method is the only
way of approaching the truth the Natural
Sciences is some in the humanities say
privileged mathematical modeling
statistics and experimentation in a way
that might turn literary analysis or
theological speculation into a little
more than entertaining diversions and
that elicits so-called physics envy
among scientists and even historians but
the Natural Sciences should not bear
this entire burden indeed if we find
ourselves tempted to look at the
humanities as a means of salvaging the
shared purposes of the University we
must recall that some leaders of the
very movement to make the humanities
central to higher education where
themselves rather dismissive of the
study of nature the humanists of the
Italian Renaissance devoted to poetry
rhetoric and history wanted to study
what is ethically significant they
committed themselves to the studio
himani taught us the study of human
things not because they were replacing
God with man but because they believed
that the technical academic theology and
philosophy of the universities had
little bearing on what really mattered
to human life the father of humanism
petrarch sees this unedifying academic
spirit as infecting even Aristotle's
treatment of morality I have read all of
aerosols moral books but I myself remain
the same Aristotle teaches what virtue
is I do not deny that but his lesson
lacks the words that sting and set a
fire and urge towards love of virtue and
hatred a vice
what subjects might have these words
that sting for Petrarch the orator can
imitate Cicero and move his audience to
a life of virtue the historian provides
the examples of moral excellence to make
such lessons concrete and the poet has
an inner and divinely given energy
infused in his spirit the study of
nature what patriarchs 14th century
contemporaries generally called physics
did not have such power and so petrarch
turned one current of the humanist
program against natural science while
petrarch spent a bit of time attacking
the Aristotelian scholastics for their
errors in their discussions of natural
phenomena he didn't stop there even if
the accounts of nature were true he says
they would not contribute anything
whatsoever to the blessed life what's
the use I beseech you of knowing the
nature of quadrupeds bowels fishes and
serpents and not knowing or even
neglecting man's nature the purpose for
which we are born and when and where to
we travel to put it simply petrarch does
not see the connection of biology and
happiness he counsels us to turn our
attention to our own human nature our
origins and our ultimate purpose indeed
petrarch sees human isms modest focus on
the human being as less arrogant and
therefore more Christian than the way
that the school man and Aristotle
inquire into nature we accept in humble
faith the secrets of nature and the
mysteries of God they attempt to seize
them in haughty arrogance they strike
heaven with their fists now humanism is
of course a very complex phenomenon
Petrarch is a difficult figure to pin
down but i have heard remarks like these
even from students of the humanities
here they have asked about the real
significance of the study of nature does
it really matter if we know about the
nature of light
the chemical components of DNA or the
positions of the stars and planets
should we not rather attend to the
meaning and purpose of human life
centuries before petrarch Aristotle
answered this last question there were
thinkers in his day like semana DS who
said that because we are human we must
think of human things because we are
mortal we must think of mortal things
Aristotle rejected such limits on human
thought we must he said so far as we can
make ourselves immortal and strain every
nerve to live in accordance with the
best thing in us even if those
activities in keeping with that divine
in us our reason only take up a small
part of our lives much more do they in
power and worth surpass everything what
does the best of humanism tell us about
the human being anyway that we are
animals capable of reasoning an
articulate speech that human beings
desire to know about things that are not
human that go beyond what is necessary
for human survival now Aristotle says
that all human beings by nature desire
to know in the opening of his
metaphysics where he immediately points
his students to a science that deals
with divine objects so aren't we just
now pitting the humanists attending to
history and poetry against the
Philosopher's devoted to metaphysics and
epistemology where does this lead the
students of the natural world whatever
his failings as a scientist Aristotle
praised those even his philosophical
opponents who dwell in intimate
association with nature and it's
phenomenon but he knew even in his day
that many of those encountering his
metaphysics or his ethics would not
understand why a major philosopher would
even take the time to compose an entire
book on the parts of
animals how few of us today allow the
image of Aristotle to biologists to
shape our picture of the philosopher so
towards the beginning of this work on
natural science on the parts of animals
Aristotle tells his readers a story
strangers came to the home of the famous
philosopher Heraclitus they perhaps
travel there expecting to hear his
profound teachings on the flux or the
fire but they found him at the furnace
in his kitchen the visitors were
embarrassed they said that they would
return at a more opportune time but
Heraclitus welcomed them in he said that
they should not be afraid to enter his
kitchen adding for there are gods here
to the fire of the humble kitchen even
Heraclitus baking bread could illuminate
the structures of reality likewise
Aristotle believed that one must not
recoil with childish aversion from the
examination of the humbler animals he
continues every realm of nature is
marvelous for just as there were gods in
the kitchen of Heraclitus so we should
venture on the study of every kind of
animal without distaste for each and all
will reveal to us something natural and
something beautiful all of nature not
only the human being not only what is
studied in metaphysics make manifest
reality and can be encountered as
beautiful indeed Aristotle answers
rather directly the charge presented to
him by Petrarch and the occasional
student of the humanities centuries
later if any person think that the
examination of the rest of the animal
kingdom an unworthy task he must hold in
like dis esteem the study of the human
being as animals ourselves the study of
biology as a study of our nature
according to its animality moreover as
actually existing beings would not we a
pro
really extend our inquiries to all that
exists but we cannot remain here with
such self orientation as rational
animals Aristotle thinks that we should
cherish the study of all natural things
because it is here that we approach what
is beautiful a rich account of the the
nature of the human being and man's
rational capacity then should nourish an
openness to the study of the natural
world from the stars to the homeless
animals and the electron for there are
gods here too I originally planned to
turn at this point to statements of
Darwin Einstein and Heisenberg about the
beauty of the natural world but if
Aristotle the Greek metaphysician and
ethicist could describe the study of
apparently ignoble animals as the divine
pursuit how much more would we expect
such language from the architects of
modern science instead I want to offer a
brief answer to Petra arcs other charge
is it not arrogance to think that we can
penetrate the secrets of nature is it
not to push oneself beyond the limits of
human nature to say that we are open to
the study of reality as a whole it would
be perversely dogmatic to say that one
can actually possess knowledge of all of
reality we certainly cannot comprehend
or contain all of what is true within
ourselves but the solution to this kind
of dogmatism is not a sceptical claim
that there is no way of relating oneself
to truth as such rather an ecstatic
conception of reason dissolves both
dogmatic arrogance and skeptical and
difference if reason is ecstatic it
means that its proper and stands in a
fundamental way outside of itself reason
is always out beyond what we possess to
paraphrase Aristotle's predecessor
Socrates we know that we are not wise
but to make such a claim that we know
that we are not wise we must have some
however mysterious however wonderful
awareness of that about which we are
ignorant and we must not stop our
pursuing indeed loving what is true it
is unsurprising then that Socrates also
says that the only thing I say I
understand is the art of love we are
part of a reality that is worthy of
being pursued desired loved even though
the whole can never be possessed this
note of love is where I will finally
leave things today what does this
critique of a narrow humanism mean for
us for me should I go down to the
laboratory should I take part in
dissections should I relearn integral
calculus I probably should but I think
that the friendships that exist here
have already created the unity that can
multiply our labors friendship let's
each of us take part in the limited and
finite but real grasp of reality
experienced by all the rest there's a
passage in agustín's confessions that
weaves together all of these themes
uniting the beauty of friendship a
shared longing for what is true and
indeed an openness to the divine when I
was with my friends my mind was occupied
with our talking and laughing reading
good books together disagreeing without
animosity as one might disagree with
one's own self and finding that our rare
disagreements seasoned our usual Concord
teaching and learning from one another
sorely missing those who were gone and
welcoming with joy those who came these
and such like signs coming from hearts
that loved one another were the kindling
of a fire that melted our minds together
and made the many of us one thank you
you